sandals spiked heels black heels one
shoe many different heels munich-based
start up me memoir launched a collection
of shoes with interchangeable heels in
2016 so how exactly does it work
we sent Micah Krueger Yura max presenter
and professional high heels wearer to
find out hi it's Lena so high heels look
fabulous but you have to be standing
still or sitting down when you wear them
because as soon as you have to actually
walk they start to hurt like crazy so it
would be great if you could swap them
for flats without having to bring along
an extra pair of shoes despite Vicky's
net Li tall with these shoes the heels
just click off and back on couldn't be
simpler
no totally normal
in fact the me meanwhile founders
wouldn't have any idea what normal high
heels feel like the young entrepreneurs
say the inspiration actually came from
their better halves a few did our
girlfriends first came up with the idea
it was a Saturday night we were out
partying we were going home exhausted
and one of them had a change of shoes
with her and another didn't mix tersh
would apply him so she was grumbling a
little I had at one point she said guys
couldn't you invent something that makes
our lives easier found on us live life
that much they spent three years
developing their concept the main
challenge was shaping the inner soul the
company now has a range of shoes with
multiple heel options that's really for
the unwind the hardest part was
perfecting the height adjustment so that
the ergonomics were right whether the
shoe was flat or high in all unique to
gear every to me hub we collaborated
with shoe makers to ensure that it
worked and felt right a little commute
with his past Micah says the Stiletto
option feels right and the others get
this you're supposed to be able to
switch the heels while you're wearing
them Mundy fwah no I'm gonna give it a
try
that was easy life and so is walking in
them
some fat punk
I'd rather not wear heels at all while
cycling it's too dangerous so I'm gonna
switch to a shorter heel Dean clad
nonsense the shoes sell for about 200
euros a pair and come with two sets of
heels each additional set costs extra
pad finances you rocket riding a bike
isn't a problem at all
strangely it feels like the shoes have
just gotten a bit bigger the curvature
of the foot in the high heel is gone now
that she was flat and it feels little
loose pockets on listen creating
changeable heels is a big technical
challenge so few designers dare to do it
Paris based Tanja Heath is one of them
she doesn't offer as many different
heights and focuses on high-fashion her
shoes cost around 400 euros German label
heel bops also combines practicality and
style here the heel itself becomes a
fashion accessory instead of removing it
designer Katarina hammers add something
to it
her heel box are made of flexible
plastic and are designed with stilettos
in mind
Jesus I wanted to end the constant drama
of getting caught between cobblestones
or sinking into grass I also wanted to
be able to wear my heels every day and
most of all dance the night away in them
Michael Kruger is testing the heel box
on her own spiked heels you know that's
the this is the nightmare of every woman
in heels your heels always get stuck in
these gaps between the cobblestones it's
awful with a little help you can even
attach the add-on heels with your shoes
on yes thank you so perfect heel box
start at 40 euros and run to 300 for the
ones with rhinestones and Micah says
there's an added benefit cause every
song is a client extra up sets it up
here these little add-on heels make your
high heels comfier probably because your
weight is distributed better they're
terrific just the thing for stylish
women who love this sky-high stilettos
and these ones give tired Tootsie's a
break without your having to change
shoes
[Music]